hold on Congress I think I've come up
with the perfect candidate to be your
new Speaker of the House I'm talking
about our own Andy rector
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
sounds just like when I was inside the
castle and they were chatting that
corner and I'm not even a politician I
don't know how I could do that okay hear
me out Andy I've thought about this I
looked it up to Speaker of the House
this is true does not have to be an
elected official oh really
yeah and check Wow yeah ladies gentlemen
Andy fits the profile perfectly he's a
white male from the Midwest
he looks Christian he's comfortable
behind a lectern and he has a closet
full of mildly ill-fitting suits and
like any good politician Andy's
perfected the art of looking someone in
the eye while lying to their face great
show tonight going
all right fatty in Congress the Speaker
of the House is third in line to become
president will similarly Andy is a thin
line to take over my job of hosting this
show because wait I'm eight who's ahead
of me
well Jim Aveeno is first then RP yeah
then our producer Jeff Ross right next
then then my assistant Sona yeah there
Sam our studio custodian followed by the
audience member sitting in seat 5c
Eisenhower mug on my desk then Trevor
the illegitimate son I refuse to
acknowledge and finally you Andy Richter
okay that makes sense it all checks out
yeah but Andy has something much better
than the speaker's gavel he has a Thor
hammer he picked up at comic-con that
thing's pretty cool
and finally most people know the Speaker
of the House from seeing him scowling
behind the president during the State of
the Union address Boehner was great at
that just scowling well Annie's been
practicing that for years during my
monologue ladies and gentlemen we've got
a great show tonight
really great
I'm so excited about it we have Grammy
Award winning artist and author of the
new book unfaithful music and
disappearing ink Elvis Costello
we have this starve the Comedy Central
series Nathan for you the Geisel airs
Nathan fielder is here
he's our guest plus santa cecilia gonna
perform
I'm here I'm gonna be here all night
hey thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography